I know it's not good so I agree yeah
yeah that's why it's a Supremacy
movement because women wanna women want
equality at the at the cost of men they
want to be above them let's be honest
though yeah yeah yeah yeah and real life
right now do you think who's got the
most power in the women women yeah and I
don't like that we make 70 to 80 of
consumer buying decisions and a bunch of
sips
tell us what we want to hear all the
time I don't like that I'm not happy
with that I'm not either like why don't
we have why don't we have DNA testing
these these I was telling these house
these
but anyways I don't know but I think
they have to change this that's all I
can say who is agenda
foreign